every business
every person
every community
now it sounds simple but in reality we
fail to do this for decades
the best of british business is the best
in the world
but we've geared our whole economy to
delivering only for those firms
and we've been complacent
about the number of jobs created which
are low pay
and insecure
when insecurity stops people getting on
and too few communities feel the benefit
of the wealth that we create
which makes people feel that hard work
is not rewarded
now
[Applause]
in a nutshell we draw our economic
strength from too few places
and like a skyscraper built without
foundations that ultimately leaves us
weak
and if you want evidence of this
look no further than the cost of living
crisis
everywhere i go
i hear the same stories
people scared about the future
worried that when winter comes they'll
face horrible choices about what to
spend their money on
pensioners
who can't afford to turn on the heating
families cutting back on what they buy
their children
but there's one thing i hear
time and time again
that worries me more than anything else
and that is working people telling me
hard work
doesn't pay
that they're working harder and harder
just to stand still
now that alarms me for two reasons
first because i've been lucky enough to
take a journey in my life
from a working class family to head of
the crown prosecution service and my
fear is an economy so wrapped by low
growth and insecurity means people from
my background can't get on
second
because honestly
what does it say about the state of
britain when working people feel that
hard work doesn't pay
what does it say about the health of our
country
the health even
of our democracy
it says an unwritten contract is broken
a contract that says in return for hard
work you get a fair reward
that you don't have to feel insecure
about your prospects
that your contribution
is respected
it's a two-way thing
a strong national economy needs everyone
making the best contribution that they
can whatever their circumstances
wherever they live
but in exchange we must make sure the
contribution working people make to that
national effort is fairly rewarded
that hard work does pay
that their effort
is respected
that they enjoy the security they need
to get all
to do all that
we need three things
growth
growth
growth
and that's why i've told the shadow
cabinet that every policy they bring
forward will be judged by the
contribution it makes to growth and
productivity because everything i want
for britain comes back to this central
mission
without growth we won't get a high-wage
economy
without growth we can't revitalize
public services
without growth we can't repair the
broken contract re-energize communities
or unite the country
low-growth countries are weaker but
standing up for the national interest
low-growth economies can't support
people from my background to get on
low growth economies can't rise to meet
the challenges of the future
challenges like climate change and i
want to be really clear on this point
we will not be distracted
by the siren calls from the right or the
left
that say economic growth and net zero do
not go together
that these two objectives are somehow in
tension
or even
that we should actively pursue a policy
of no growth
i reject that completely it is totally
the wrong way round
a plan for net zero needs growth a plan
for growth needs net zero
this is about the future of course
fail to tackle climate change and you
can forget about growth
there's no bigger risk to business
look at how our infrastructure has
struggled in the last few weeks in the
heat
but tackling climate change is also an
opportunity to create wealth in the here
and now
that's why labour is committed to a
climate investment pledge worth 28
billion pounds until 2030 and we see
that pledge as a as a down payment that
will unlock the private investment which
delivers the next generation of jobs
because
the way i see it
some nation is going to lead the world
in electric vehicles in floating
offshore wind in new hydrogen and
technological
developments
why not britain
why not britain
but to maximize our collective
contribution
we must be clear about the kind of
growth that we need
the growth the growth i want for britain
is strong
secure
and fair
strong because it will build a
foundation where every business and
every person plays a role
secure because it will produce good jobs
that don't leave people feeling insecure
and fair because it will unlock the
potential of every place
every community
every town
and every city
this last point is so important and
strikes at the structural weakness of
our economy
it's not an issue of city versus town
the productivity gap between our cities
and their equivalents in europe
is already too big
and too many of our towns don't have a
fair chance to contribute in an economy
still dominated
by london and the south east
this is the hurdle we must clear
we need growth that is strong secure and
fair to re-establish that contract
between people and prosperity
the distinction i would make is this
an economy can grow
and leave some of its people behind
but a nation based on contribution
cannot grow in that way
but of course all promises need a plan
boosterism and fantasy economics are not
the same as ambition
so today i want to share with you
some of the plans labor has to reboot
growth
and set out five principles that will
guide my government in growing our
economic contribution
these are
first
we will be financially responsible
second we will be distinctively british
third we will work in partnership with
business
fourth we will re-energize communities
and spread economic power
and fifth we will refocus our investment
on boosting productivity
now let me take each of these in turn
starting with the most direct
financial responsibility
the risk of rising inflation could not
be clearer
so we will not announce a single penny
of day-to-day spending without saying
how we would pay for it
we will only borrow to invest to meet
the challenges of the future
that's what our climate investment
pledge is all about
and we will set a target to reduce debt
as an overall share of our economy
that's the responsible thing to do
and contrast that
with the conservative competition
to waste more of your money
that contrast could not be starker
with me and with rachel reeves
you will always get
sound finances
careful spending
strong secure
and fair growth
there will be no magic monetary
economics with us
my second principle is that we must grow
our contribution in a distinctively
british way
this means two things
first that we need resilient supply
chains in sectors which are vital for
british security and growth
that's why we have a strategy to buy
make and sell more in britain
why three billion pounds of our climate
investment pledge will help forge a new
future for our steel industry
and why we have committed to new public
procurement rules that will build up
britain's suffering capabilities in key
industries
and let me be clear
it isn't protectionist to say this
or somehow old-fashioned
britain will always be an outward-facing
confident trading nation
but all around the world businesses are
looking again at the resilience of their
supply chains
reacting to the crises we face
and will face in the future
countries must do the same
second
a british approach means we can't
transplant the economic model of another
country onto ours
two weeks ago i met olaf schultz the
chancellor of germany and leader of our
sister party the spd
he is showing that when leveling up is
based on practical plans
not far-fetched promises
amazing things can happen
in eastern germany right now some of the
poorest parts of the country are leading
the continent in the lucrative race to
develop batteries that store renewable
energy
this is what can be done
and as lisa mandy has felt out just
because the tory commitment to leveling
up is dead
doesn't mean the idea of leveling up is
dead
labour will take it on
but to do this in a way which isn't pure
boosterism
we must be honest
about british strengths
take manufacturing
britain has an extraordinary genius when
it comes to manufacturing
we lead the world in pharmaceuticals
bioscience aerospace
the nissan factory in sunderland is one
of the most productive in europe
and the kovid 19 vaccine developed by
astrazeneca and oxford university has
saved millions of lives around the world
when i was in airbus in filton recently
i saw them working with 3d engineering
literally shaping components by bringing
together particles of matter in a way
that's unimaginable in the factory my
dad used to work
we can and should take advantage of
these strengths
the road to higher growth and
productivity runs right through them
but we're not germany
the role manufacturing plays in our
economy will always be different
and we have super power strengths in
universities in creative industries in
exporting services that other countries
can't compete with
the challenge in both services and
manufacturing
is the
same the best of british is the best in
the world
and the way we stay competitive is to
get more of it
more innovation
more new technology
more research and development more
unlocking the commercial power of our
universities and specializing in the
knowledge rich industries of the future
and more startups
which is why we've asked lord jim
o'neill to look at how we can make
britain the best country in the world to
start a new business
and why we have a plan to make brexit
work
that doesn't ignore the strength of our
services
or our universities
but an economy that grows
on contribution
must rest on strong foundations
foundations that are there in every
community
that is why the work that rachel's been
doing on the everyday economy is so
important
retail
education health and care
we saw in the pandemic
how much of the wealth we create depends
on these sectors being strong
and for too long industrial strategies
simply ignore them
and with that ignored one of britain's
distinctive challenges on growth
labour's industrial strategy will
contain a plan for the everyday economy
and our new deal for working people will
introduce new employment rights to give
greater security for people working in
it
that brings me to my third principle
partnership
for growth that is strong secure and
fair
we must work together
we need a real partnership
between state and market
business and worker
the everyday economy and the
technological frontier
and it's the job of a modern industrial
strategy to make sure this partnership
grows our collective contribution
not in a nostalgic way where government
directs the activities of businesses
modern industrial strategy
isn't about growing the size of the
state
it's about what the state does
how it supports business to innovate and
to grow
brings in the creative brilliance of our
universities
and applies them to the national
missions
that we must all contribute towards
whether that's leading the world in
artificial intelligence
or applying our genius to the challenge
of net zero
here at the spine center in the middle
of the knowledge quarter innovation all
around us
just down the road at the materials
innovation factory
the university of liverpool and unilever
are partnering
to bridge the gap between scientific
research and production
developing the new materials we need to
tackle climate change
or discover life-saving new medicines
we need to do so much more of this
mission-driven partnership
but the government doesn't have a plan
and
we have a massive job on our hands when
it comes to private investment
for decades we've trailed our
competitors
in france businesses invest around 30
more relative to gdp every year
if we could just close this gap we would
land a serious blow in our battle
against low growth
now we know it requires public
investment
that's why we have our climate
investment pledge
we know it requires fair taxation
which is why we will scrap business
rates and replace them with a system
that levels the playing field
but we also know
it requires stability
and that requires institutions
that take a serious
patient
long-term view about what needs to be
done
so today i can announce we will
establish an industrial strategy council
and we will go further by putting it on
a statutory footing
it will provide advice that shapes
policy
in the way that climate change committee
does or the office of budget
responsibility
a permanent part of the landscape
that sets out our strategic national
priorities
that go beyond the political cycle
brings in the expertise of business
science and unions
holds us to account for our decisions
and builds confidence for investors
that will boost long-term growth and
productivity
my fourth and fifth principles are best
taken together
because spreading power and raising the
productivity of the economy everywhere
are fundamental to growing our
contribution
on spreading power i've asked gordon
brown to look at new forms of economic
devolution
to make sure the decisions about things
that drive regional growth
like skills
infrastructure attracting investment are
all made by people with skin in the game
labor will not attempt to run our
leveling up strategy from the center
nor will we offer it alongside a
divisive argument about north versus
south
city versus town to me they've always
felt like false choices
a productive liverpool
is good for birkenau
a strong dudley
is good for birmingham
and each has a shared fate
in the wider battle against regional
inequality
but we must also recognize
that every place needs the power to grow
its own economy
so our reforms will allow devolved and
local government to make long-term
financial decisions
to reap the rewards of investment in
their economy
that way you make sure that every city
every town every place
takes ownership
of their contribution
that people
and businesses with a long-term
commitment to their community
work together
in partnership
it's what labour is delivering in power
and it's what labor will deliver in
national government
but as well spreading power
real leveling up also requires
investment
and this is where my labour party will
move on from the old ideas
because the old approach focused on
growing the pie in any way possible
then redistributing
but this is not strong secure
and fair growth
it leaves too many people in insecure
jobs
where their hard work is not fairly
rewarded
too many communities locked out from the
benefits of growth
and redistribution
can't repair the contract
now there's no point looking to the
right on this
the evidence of the past decade shows
they will only give us stagnation
but what we will do
what winning center-left parties around
the world have done
is to adopt a new approach to investment
and approach the us treasury secretary
janet yellen has called modern
supply-side economics
it rests
in part
on a universal truth about social
democracy
a strong economy needs strong public
services
and strong public services need reform
and investment
but it also rests on something more
subtle
because the investments we make now
should have a laser-like focus on
boosting long-term productivity across
the country
not just quick winds
in the southeast
which means we must learn to focus on
the supply side
on growing the collective contribution
everywhere
now you can see this in our approach to
fully funded plans for public service
reform
whether it's our 8500 new mental health
professionals
or our national excellence program for
schools that will tackle
the educational inequality at the heart
of low productivity
our policies are not just an investment
in the health and well-being of our
community
they are also an investment in the
long-term growth and productivity of the
country
there's no tension here
just look at how many people at the
moment can't work
because of their health
a highly skilled and healthy nation and
a fast-growing modern economy depend on
each other
i never think it's too hard to identify
what people want from politics
at the moment it's probably easier than
usual
people want a fresh start for britain
they want the opportunity to get on
and above all they want to be free from
the insecurity of the cost of living
crisis
the approach to growth i've set out
today will challenge my party's instinct
it pushes us to care as much about
growth and productivity as we have done
in the past about redistribution and
investment
not to hark back to our old ideas in the
face of new challenges
you will see a clear contrast between my
labor party and the thatcherite cosplay
on display tonight
the difference between a labour party
ready to take britain forward
and a tory party that wants to take us
back to the past
between labor growth
tory stagnation
that will be the choice at the next
election and we are ready
ready to renew the contract with working
people
ready to reboot our economy and end the
cost of living crisis
ready to unlock the contribution of
every business every person and every
community
and deliver the strong secure and fair
growth our country needs thank you very
much
thank you
i think we've got a number of questions
starting with erica
you mentioned liz trust and mushy soon a
few times then isn't the problem that
tory leadership contest is just drowning
out you and any policies you might want
to announce this summer
no i don't think that at all i think
what we're seeing from the leadership
contest is
um
two individuals who are part of the
problem we've had 12 years now of
stagnation they voted for every one of
those 15 tax rises and now they're
trying to distance themselves as quickly
as possible from it so
their answers if you like our
are too small for our country for the
challenge that we face and that's why
i've set out a strategic plan for the
future
and
you know i think the change we need now
is much more fundamental than a change
at the top of the tory party we need to
change a government and fresh start for
britain thank you erica elena
hi eleanor from the press association um
what exactly is your position on public
ownership of energy and water firms you
appear to have ruled out nationalization
yet you still have some interest in
common ownership can you explain what
that means well look i take a pragmatic
approach rather than an ideological one
agree with what rachel reeve said this
morning
having come through the pandemic
it's very important we have very very
clear priorities
and that's why we've set out fiscal
rules already as an opposition rachel
did that at uh conference last year
that's way ahead of the general election
setting out our priorities and my
priority as i hope is obvious from this
morning is growth
the mission of the next labor government
will be growth
and you know that
partnership with business is where i see
that growth coming from so my approach
here is is pragmatic not ideological my
mission is growth and underpinning that
mission is a partnership arrangement
with business where the mission is set
by an incoming labour government and we
empower business to work with us on
delivering on that mission
thank you eleanor i think we've got mark
from the guardian
hi um
hi um
you talked about uh uh sort of um
changing position uh not being trapped
in
uh parties history
uh
more focused on growth and productivity
but didn't the labour party didn't blair
and gordon brown's labour party
concentrate on growth and productivity
or did they
let it fall through the gaps oh they did
concentrate on growth and productivity
and
let's sum it up if the economy in the
last 12 years on the tourists had grown
at the same rate as it did under the
last labour government we would have
billions of pounds to spend on our
public services what i want to do is
build on that and take it forward
and to get away from the idea that
redistribution of the pie is all you
need to grow your economy all you need
for fairness what i want is growth so
that everyone everywhere can make a
contribution that is
for them their place their town their
village
their city and get a fair reward for
that contribution so it's to take that
forward but the answer to every question
about the economy has to be growth first
and you can't go to tax and spend until
you've answered the growth question we
put a serious answer to the growth
question on the table this morning
contrast that to the fantasy economics
going on in the tory leadership race
where they're making unfunded spending
commitments the magic monetary is
working overtime
with us you've got a serious plan for
the future and then i think i've got
liam
hi liam hi
yeah welcome to liverpool i don't know
if you've er ever got a train across the
north but i haven't been many times if
you have you may not have arrived at
your destination in some time um just to
push you on this on this public
ownership issue it seems like some
members of the shadow cabinet have
maintained that particularly when it
comes to rail the public ownership of
bringing the trains back into public
control remains a labor priority um can
i push you on that one please yeah
firstly i have taken that trade many
many times
because
before i was a politician i was director
of public prosecutions and i had staff
um in a hundred offices across the whole
of the united kingdom in including here
down the liverpool in there
and so i've done those journeys between
our cities and places
across the northeast the north and the
northwest many many times and absolutely
understand
why people feel so let down by a
government that promised to change that
um with the rail system that they
promised for the north and have
absolutely failed to deliver on it but
whether it comes to rail or anything
else liam
i want to be pragmatic about this rather
than ideological
you know i think
what some of our mayors and metro mayors
are doing with public transport is the
right way forward absolutely focus
on um keeping the price down and making
sure there's control over where uh
things go particularly buses recently
steve roberts here we had a very good
discussion recently about what we do
with our buses and i think that is the
difference that labour mayor's metro
mayors can make in power but liam as i
say pragmaticalness
rather than ideological
but i absolutely understand the
frustrations of everybody trying to use
the rail service particularly going
across the country rather than up and
down the country it's been
broken for a very long time the
government very very clear commitment to
it including a new line
and they've broken all of those
commitments and that is the
story of the last 12 years empty
promises
um never really meant
always broken and there are just so many
examples of it it's why the tory party
is in such a mess it's why the change we
need for our country is not just to
change the person at the top of the tory
party they're the problem they're not
the solution
we need a general election we need a
change of government thank you liam
thank you everybody for coming this
morning thank you
you